things are getting serious between
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
a source tells et the reality star's
family has
never seen her like this i love it
the mom of three has been dating the
blink 182 drummer for a few months
now and according to et's source the two
are quote
obsessed with each other quote they're
so in love and
constantly fawning over one another they
have such a strong connection
and can't get enough of each other the
source knows that travis makes court
feel
so special and is always showing her how
much he loves her and how important she
is to him
quote courtney has been extremely loving
towards him as well and has also been
making a big effort to show how much
she cares i love you
[Music]
and according to et source the 42 year
old's famous fam
is super happy for her quote they're
also in a little bit of shock because
they've never seen her like this before
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
also shocking the risque gift travis got
inspired by court on tuesday the
musician took to his insta story to show
off his heretic
by goop candle the scent it's called
this smells like courtney's orgasm
the keeping up with the kardashians star
reposted the photo to her own insta
story
this is such a dream come true courtney
and travis started dating
in january and in just a few short
months
they have vacationed together packed on
the pda
and travis even got quartz name inked on
his chest
for mother's day the 45 year old went
all out
gifting court with a massive floral
arrangement
and a source previously told et that the
two
are talking forever courtney and travis
are in love
and have talked about their future and
the possibility of getting engaged and
[Music]
married
you